today I wanted to talk to you about
building learning to rank or LTR models
for search using large language models
also called llms or Foundation
models so let me introduce myself very
briefly my name is sujit Paul and I work
at LC Health uh I used to be a search
engineer but since then I moved to doing
more and more machine learning and data
science work so nowadays most of the
work that I do is at the intersection of
uh search and machine learning and as
you can see um I have a pretty broad but
probably unsurprising range of interests
given the work that I do um I have been
working on a generative AI project since
the middle of this year and this
actually started out as a way to do
automatic evaluation of our search stack
before labels were available from our
domain experts but then it morphed into
what I'm going to describe so it was a
bit of a site project uh which we ended
up not using finally but because of its
history I ended up using a lot of the
infrastructure set up for this project
this the main project the generative AI
project is talking about so in any case
uh here is my email and other social
media coordinates uh in case you anybody
wants to get in touch
right
um I also one other thing I have posted
the link to the slides and the software
in the uh Discord channel so you'll be
able to get it from there as well you
don't have to copy from here so any case
here is my agenda what I intended to
cover uh first I will describe the
project at a very high level um and then
I will go into the details of the
implementation component wise and here I
will cover some theory in learning on
learning to rank uh models since I think
uh this may be new to at least some of
you right and finally I will cover
issues that still need to be addressed
and what we are doing or planning to do
to address
them with that let's start so few years
ago I learned about this what why how
framework uh to read academic papers
quickly and uh I I became a you know a
fan right so since then I find that I
can apply this idea to other areas as
well such as communicating an idea or
describing a project such as this one so
to address the what um that is what is
the big idea here essentially it boils
down to getting llms to generate
relevance judgments for a query with
respect to a document then using these
judgments to train an LTR model and
using the LTR model as a ranker for
search uh you know for search
results so essentially the final product
is now a search pipeline that has
learned to return relevant results based
on what the llm considers relevance so
it makes sense because fine tuning
search is usually a very labor intensive
Affair and so if you can get machines to
take you part of the way there I think
of it as a
win um so why do I think this idea has
legs traditionally l has been popular in
domains such as e-commerce where there
is a good signal in user feedback such
as you know views clicks add to card Etc
not so much in areas like Health where
we get our in-house domain experts to um
hand label judgment lists it's it's
really back breaking work and it's no
wonder that it's so hard to get enough
enough judgments train models so
essentially what ends up happening is
that uh you know search Engineers would
end up treating these labels that get
generated as a validation set to
validate their hand tune changes of
course I mean having this is still
better than tuning and hoping that it
all works in production obviously um but
if you can harness machine learning to
build LTR models you know not only do we
get this you know like a less pey
solution but uh in general it's kind of
you know gives you a more well-rounded
solution so it's a better solution in my
opinion and llms especially the large
ones are quite good at uh mimicking
human preferences so it makes sense to
use them for generating judgments
instead of human
experts and here you know I I'll point
to this as maybe this is just an appeal
to Authority on my side um but even
teams such as this one from Microsoft
research they seem to be actively
looking in this possibility and they
have implemented this idea that I'm
talking about even though they don't
share too many details in this
paper I also wanted to show you the
results of my experiments up front as
another reason why this idea might have
legs
before we built our LTR models we
evaluated a bunch of Baseline search
pipelines pure lexical search pure
Vector search using you know out of the
box elastic search and quadrant uh
Vector
stores another one was our knowledge
graph enhanced lexical search pipeline
hand tuned by our search Engineers over
the last few years and we then trained
four models a pointwise regression model
four LTR models basically a point-wise
regression model and pairwise models
rank net Lambda rank Rank and Lambda
Mark and of these rank net did the best
and not surprisingly the hand tune
pipeline was the winner of course I mean
if you look at the top red line here um
the ultimate winner in fact even
although not by a whole lot as you can
see here so our ranknet model has a map
at you know a mean average Precision at
10 of
8.38 whereas the hand tune model had
8.50 which I still think is a win since
we approached the performance of the
tune pipeline tuned by multiple peoples
over a number of years with ML models
that were built with training data also
generated from ml models so essentially
you know almost no human effort except
for programmer
effort so okay now now on to the how
here is the high level architecture it's
a supervised learning pipeline so there
is a training and an inference pipeline
there is also an evaluation bid down in
the corner here to validate that the
model we trained will perform adequately
during inference and I will cover each
of these components in more detail but
at a high level during training we want
to take some uh queries uh send them
through elastic search generate
judgments from the query uh query
document pairs that were generated from
the you know from elastic search using
an llm and then train an LTR model using
these judgments and for inference we
take an incoming query
um generate the top 50 search results
using untune lexical search from elastic
search uh use the LTR model as a ranker
to score and return the top 10 relevant
results and for evaluation um we get the
llm to deliver judgments on the ranked
results that we just saw and use that to
determine the performance of the ltrr
model so I will refer back to this
diagram many times during this
presentation so the steps will become
clearer as I
continue so now that we know what the
presentation is all about uh let's go
deeper first up query
sampling so in my case I was trying to
build an additional component to an
existing search pipeline that would
handle a subset of the queries that are
already being consumed at the moment but
not handled optimally right so I decided
to sample from our existing query log
the objective here was to find queries
in the logs that were similar to our
gold set queries for some measure of
similarity such as similar number of
tokens or similar number of medical
entities in the tokens and essentially I
pretended that these uh you know these
two things you know in in my um gold set
were normally distributed and I use the
mean plus or minus plus or minus
standard deviation bounds uh to filter
out queries from the log so the
algorithm is that I used is basically in
the last two bullet points here and I
did a few other things such as um you
know removing non-english and
navigational queries from the list
however depending on your situation um
you may actually need to do something
different so for example if this is a
green field project um you uh May need
to build up a representative set of
queries maybe doing automated question
answering on your Corpus right or some
other method um yeah so next up is the
label generator component which is
basically an LM a large language model
that generates judgments given a query
document pair so we used anthropics
Cloud for this
task and for the point-wise regression
model you remember um if you remember I
talked about four different LTR models
so for the first one the pointwise
regression model here is The Prompt that
we used so we provided the llm the query
and the document these are placeholders
they will actually you know during the
actual um you know work the query and
the document will be replaced by the
appropriate query and the document right
so we provide the llm the query and
document text and prompt it to generate
the a judgment of relevant or irrelevant
I also ask it to provide the reasoning
for the Judgment even though I actually
don't use it in the hope that going
through the reasoning will enable it to
provide uh better judgment ments similar
to zero short Chain of Thought prompting
and the distribution of judgments across
the training of about 500 queries here
is shown in the bar chart you can see
here and as you can see it's not
perfectly balanced but it is good enough
to train a binary classifier regression
model for the pairwise rank net model
our second model we need to provide the
llm with a query and a pair of document
texts right so you can see these three
here um and prompted to generate a
binary document one or document two
judgment depending on which which text
is more relevant to the query so note
that you don't need to generate
judgments for all pairs of documents for
a given query just a small subsid Isen
of maybe 5 to 10% my strategy was to
generate the top 20 documents from ltic
search for each query and then create
pairs using the first document is the
left hand side and the other 19
documents as the right hand side of the
pair so essentially 19 pairs for each
query 500 queries in all and as you can
see the the data distribution the class
distribution you know is actually also
quite balanced here between the two
classes and finally for our next two
models Lambda Rank and Lambda Mart uh
they are both pairwise models like rank
typ but they require the data to be
provided in a listwise format that is
for each query input should be the top
ke documents along with the numeric
score indicating its relevance the so
the prompt here provides a query and a
document as before but there is also the
description of a scoring rubric which
ask the LM to and then it asked the LM
to provide a score so I initially tried
with a three-point scale 1 two three but
results were not very good so I tried
this fiveo scale that you can see here
and if you recall from the results slide
I showed earlier both the models train
on this data perform relatively poorly
and I think it's because the resulting
distribution that you can see here of
the classes is quite imbalanced right uh
and moreover I think in general numeric
scores may be harder for the model to
generate accurately compared to Binary
judgments just as it's harder for human
experts because of the qualitative
nature of the judgments and the scoring
right so now that we have seen the
labels um we will now look at the
feature generator for those of you who
have used psychic learn uh the label
generation process is we just discussed
um are the Y values right uh the list of
labels and now what we'll do is we'll
generate the x value
so essentially it means that we convert
the query document pair into a vector of
numeric features such that the ml model
can consume and this is where we might
need some domain expertise at least the
way I have done it here but uh you don't
you don't really need to I mean if
you're a in a new domain where you don't
understand the data too well another
option could be to just create a feature
vector by encoding the query and
document using a suitable embedding
model this strategy is similar to how
you would uh approach fine-tuning a
vector-based retriever in a reader
retriever search
pipeline um the embedding Vector is
analogous to a manually created feature
Vector except that it's just not as
interpretable because it's you know it's
all you know 300 Dimensions or 500
Dimensions or whatever and depending on
how well you know the domain it may or
may not be better than a manually
created feature Vector so I went ahead
and did it anyway because I thought I
could do a better job than you know just
using an
embedding so the approach I took for
feature generation is to manually choose
uh features and encode them in a feature
Vector it is inspired by the features uh
described in this Microsoft um learning
to rank data set's
website and at a high level you can
classify features as query features
document features or query document
features depending on where they came
from in addition to the query suggested
the Microsoft website I added the
concept overlap that you can see here
the concept and the semantic group
overlap this is from a Knowledge Graph
and the idea was to bring some knowledge
graph awareness into these features and
there's is also the cosine similarity
feature which brings some awareness of
Co you know the semantic similarity
between these fields and the query right
so and for each of these highlighted
features these are essentially um you
know field level features we compute the
value for these four different fields
here the title the section title the
breadcrumbs and the text and the effect
is that you know you kind of build bring
some content awareness into the features
right so in the sense that these are the
fields that are important for our Search
application and for each of these uh per
field term frequency R TF and term
frequency inverse document frequency uh
tfid features for each field we capture
multiple aspects of this right such as
the minimum the maximum the mean and
standard deviation and the idea here
again is to provide the model with an
awareness of the shapes of these
features so I also wanted to
cover um where we got these features
from so you could use it as a template
for your own starter features if you
were to implement something like this
some of these features are generated
just just by counting right such as the
number of query tokens and overlapping
query tokens and query um Concepts
respectively so these are the ones in
Loop here and the tfidf document
features and the bm25 scores are
generated using elastic searches term
vector and search Services respectively
so you can actually make the you know
the um you know these are generated from
the elastic search index based on its
own statistics The Entity and Knowledge
Graph features are generated using K
minor our proprietary dictionary based n
system that recognizes entities in our
medical Knowledge Graph and Vector
similarity uses a pre-trained sentence
Transformers model to compute the
vectors and cach them in a quadrant
Vector store from which they are
retrieved during feature generation and
using these sources in all we have 61
features per query document um
pair so now let's look at the model as I
mentioned we have a training Pipeline
and an inference Pipeline and the model
appears in both obviously in the
training pipeline the trained LTR model
is the output of the pipeline and in the
inference pipeline the LTR model is used
to rerank incoming search
results and this is the part where I
promis to give you some background on
LTR so LTR is a large in active field of
research um but LTR models in general
can be classified as either pointwise
pairwise or listwise the classification
identifies the kind of input the consume
and the kind of ranking information they
learn to provide so in our diagrams I
show the input as query and a document
while LTR models are not very much
different from say you know psyched
learn models which I think most of us
here are more familiar with anyway so
the quer and document pair inputs and
the triple in case of rank net so it's
in in the case of rank net you have a
triple um are converted into a feature
vector by the feature generator we just
talked about so once that happens input
to the model is just Matrix of features
each row corresponding to a single input
and output is a list of labels one for
each input so feature Vector in
judgement prediction out just like any
old you know cych Lear
model so I have shown this chart before
at least actually both these charts
before but just to recap uh I tried
training four different LTR models
they're represented by the blue bars in
the top histogram here the red dotted
lines represent the three baselines we
evaluated before building the models in
terms of performance of the various LTR
models
you would expect Lambda Lambda Mt to
perform the best followed by Lambda rank
then rank net and then the regression
model however in our case we observe
that rank net performs the best and as I
mentioned earlier I think the poor
performance of the Lambda Rank and
Lambda mod May at least have something
to do with the unbalanced nature of the
data that we gave it you know it was
trained
with so um in terms of implementations
when we talk about LTR models usually
people think of LTR plugins that are
available as part of elastic search and
solar or other um platforms as well
search platforms so I thought about
going that route initially but that
would mean messing with configuration
for a search index that is being
currently used by other developers which
seemed risky so I built this pipeline
instead with Standalone models so from
an implementation point of view
pointwise regression is the simplest and
most intuitive it takes a vector
generated from a query document pair and
learns to return a number between zero
and one or binary judgments relevant or
irrelevant so to as far as
implementation goes I built a two- layer
fully connected neural network but you
can get comparable results with a
psychic learn svm based classifier
regressor as well I tried it it does
have very very similar results so the
other three are pairwise models rank net
is the first pairwise model it takes a
query and a pair of documents and
returns a binary classification as to
which document is more relevant I
implemented as a three- layer Siamese
Network um and and for the other two the
Lambda Rank and the Lambda Mart I
adapted the code that was in the l2r
repository which which I have linked to
here um both of them need the input in a
listwise format called svm light so I
have pre-processing code in the code in
there to build you know from my score
judgments I build the sbm light format
and this is because they need the
ranking and scores for training both the
ranking and the scores right so in and
internally they convert the input to
pairwise and use the scores to learn the
difference
oops um sorry um and internally they um
you know they they um converted to
pairwise and
U give me a
second yeah sorry um and uh so that that
helps them learn the score um the the
relevance labels faster and I and this
part uh with the dmlc XG boost I found
out about later but turns out that I
could have also used XG boost with the
rank objectives that are shown here to
get the Lambda Rank and Lambda mod um
model implementations but by that time
it was kind of quite late so you know I
ended up not using
it um so there is an additional step for
uh rank net that I wanted to cover as
you may have noticed in the pointwise
Lambda Rank and Lambda m models the
output is a numeric score which can be
used to rank the documents directly
right however output of rank net is
either minus one or plus one depending
on which document is more relevant so in
order to generate a document ranking
from this information we need a rank
Matrix which is just a matrix of scores
for document pairs in this example here
we have collected a bunch of relevance
judgment predictions for documents D1 to
D5 which you can think of as maybe the
top five results for a query um and you
know we want to produce a ranked
response for those top five results so
and so in The Matrix the elements along
the diagonal are obviously zero since
all documents are as relevant as
themselves you
know and the upper triangular Matrix is
a mirror image of the lower triangular
Matrix since if document D2 is more
relevant than D1 then D1 by necessity
has to be less relevant than D2
right and once we have this Matrix um
you know minus one plus one fill the
Matrix up and then we just take the you
know row sums of each and then we rank
um you know using the row sums we rerank
the documents using their row
sums the approach requires us to do n *
n minus1 over2 comparisons before we can
generate the rank list so you would need
to generate around you know for top 50
results for example you would need to
generate around 1,200 predictions so
that is one thing to think about and the
blog post link here that I've linked to
below has more information about this
technique so one other thing to note is
that all our pairwise LTR models are
related to each other in a kind of an
evolutionary way right so Chris bergus
has written a paper on on this it's a
very informative paper if you you know
are curious you know you should go read
this um so basically all of them um
learn by gradient sent uh for rank knet
the gradient is the difference of cost
to swap a pair of documents Plus versus
the difference in their
scores now Lambda rank is an improvement
over rank net in that the gradient is
multiplied by the difference in the ndcg
scores of the pair wise being you know
the pair being considered right and the
Lambda in its name refers to this
product of um you know gradient and the
ndcg difference and the net result is
that it leads to faster convergence and
the results tend to be more in line with
search relevance
expectations and Lambda Mart takes a
slightly different approach it uses
gradient boosting which is a bagging
mechanism so it works by iteratively
combining weak Learners that focus and
addressing the errors observed in the
previous week learner so if you think in
terms of decision trees as you can see
in this diagram here you might find
first focus in a tree that uses a small
subset of features and check its
performance and then add another tree
with another subset that together
addresses the errors made by the first
one and so on right and so Lambda Mart
is basically a combination of Mart
multiple additive regression trees a
type of gradient boosting technique and
it calculates the lambdas similar to how
Lambda rank does it hence Lambda Mt
so um any case in order to determine now
which ranker performs the best for our
use case we needed a way to evaluate it
and that's our evaluation bit right
here so to evaluate a query document
pair we provide um it to an LM and
prompted to generate a relevant
irrelevant pair identical in fact to
what we did to generate labels for the
pointwise model we then roll up these
judgments across all top 10 documents in
the results for the query giving us
Precision at 10 score for the model for
the given query so let's say for some
query the llm said seven results are the
top 10 were relevant so in that case our
um Precision at 10 would be 0.7 and if
it said three results of the top 10 were
relevant then it would be P at 10 would
be
0.3 so we then roll up these scores
across all our queries in the gold set
giving us the mean average Precision at
10 or map at 10 for the model so we
evaluate all four models using the same
fixed list of queries so we have a
comparative you know score for to so we
can rank them and one thing to note is
that even though um so search is
generally regarded as a rank aware matri
uh M uh application a rank aware
application right however mean average
Precision is usually you know thought of
as a rank agnostic metric because it
doesn't have any idea of the ranks here
so the reason we use map instead of
other metrics is because our application
needed all top 10 results to be treated
as equally
relevant but in applications where
ranking matters this pipeline can be
trivially adapted to generate rank aware
metrics such as ndcg at 10 or Mr at 10
as
well so um next let me sum up what we
talked about and look look at how we can
improve
further so to conclude the LTR approach
yields High relevance models quickly and
with relatively little effort compared
to the traditional approach to building
search applications this is because llms
address one of the main bottlenecks for
LTR adoption that are the difficulty of
creating enough labels of sufficiently
high quality to train LTR based um
relevance models and thus llms can be
used to jumpstart the development of an
ltrb pipeline in environments where or
domains where this wasn't an option
earlier right and because human
judgments are difficult and expensive to
acquire using machines to do that uh
seems to make
sense and it seems like a good option to
consider when building your um you know
own uh next Search application in
addition unlike uh purely statistical or
purely knowledge gr driven or purely
vector-based approaches that people
generally go for in you know search
pipelines the future generation step in
our LTR approach allows developers to
inject information from various sources
so you can actually mix and match
potentially good ideas from different
kinds of pipelines so in that sense it's
actually I think uh it's Superior to
just using one
method so the other thing I wanted to
point out is that while I built the
first two LTR models from scratch and
adapted the to from existing code bases
they're all fairly standard well
established general purpose models that
people have experimented with and have
found to be effective so nothing much to
do there to improve things really right
but I think the main Innovation here is
that we use llms to generate judgment
labels and there may be scope for
improvement here so during ER during an
eror analysis exercise we found that our
original assumption that llns can
accurately mimic human preferences was
not completely accurate and while there
was a large overlap around 70% between
human and llm judgments in general llms
tended to be more
lenient um than human experts and you
can see it reflected in the charts at
the bottom here so in the leftmost one
we have a confusion Matrix and you can
see a lot of cases here where the human
has provided an irrelevant judgment but
the llm thinks it's relevant right
similarly if you go to the rightmost one
the the orange um you know the
distribution curve is basically the
human represents human judgments human
scores and the blue one represents the
llm scores and as you can see there is a
fair bit of um you know overlap between
the two but the Ln tends to assign
higher scores and the middle one shows
the correlation between um the um you
know the two different kinds of scores
and as you can see the correlation
coefficient around 0.4 which is on the
low side and uh and you can also see
that llms tend to make more mistakes as
the relevance increases
I apologize for interrupting we we do
have just like a minute and a half left
if you want to start wrapping things up
and then you can um continue any
conversations over in Discord okay okay
thanks so yeah all right so anecdotally
based on what we see in their analysis I
found that llm tries a bit too hard to
predict relevance and make some leaps of
reasoning where the human would not
consider valid so I think that's the
main area we would focus on future work
and I'm going to go really quick one way
we thought of is to you know use an
active learning Pipeline and U you know
the idea here is that successive
iterations will make it better and each
time you take low confidence U judgments
and you um
um you know have humans annotate those
those pieces the second one was uh using
a you know like a mixture of experts
multiple llms to Ensemble it and we saw
that uh you know this this is the the
diagonal is the the the majority
decision and the correlation with the
you know the llm and we saw that Claude
had pretty good U results here which is
why we used it and the third one is you
know like the prompt engineering uh
thing I was using is fairly basic so
there are things that I plan to do with
better prompting right and I think uh
that's it um thank you very much for
being such a great audience um you know
and staying with me so far and thanks to
Pata Global organizers for providing me
a platform to share my ideas Finance the
community the source code is here I've
also shared on Discord and I can take
questions if there is time or we can go
to Discord and I can uh we're actually
out of time but um you can like you said
join um everybody in Discord and
continue those conversations thank you
so much for your time today all right go
thanks